clinique unique en son genre.
faire une petite injection,
ce spapapas bien long.
- Jusqu'à maintenant,
ces locaux servaient
des futures infirmìeres.
OnOnOn rajoute des degrés de
réalisme par-dessus ce qui
existe déjà.
constate le niveau de
raffinement des mauiuiuins
utilisés.
- Il va falloir quelqu'un
aujourd'hui.
- Mais il est ici pour visiter
les locaux de nouvelle clinique
d'infirmières qui ouvre dès
lundi.r r r r r r r r r r r r r.
- Trois infirmières vont
recevoir et tratier ici
des cas non-urgents,
référés palalalalalalalalalalal.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ
ministre de la Santé, Québec
- Si on parle de 250 à
par semaine, alors qu'ici à
la Cité de Laval, on fai p p peu
près 3000 rendez-vous d'urgence,
ça veut dire qu'on parle de 10 à
des urgences pour le faire au
bon endroit.
- Et parce qu'elle est dans
l'univtétété, cette clinique
sera aussi un lieu de formation
pour les futures infirmières.Faé
sciences infirmières, UdeM
- C'est la première fois que ça
va se faire vraiment, que
l'Université de Montesesesesesee
d'un CISSS, d'une organisation
de santé.  Alors, moi,
je suis très fière de ça.
DANI
recteur Université de Montréal
- Donner le service à la
communauté pour essayer de
dégager un peu le réseau de
lui, puis en même temps on fait
la formation, pour ntututudiants
et nos étudiantes en sciences
infirmières.
formation des infirmières
praticeseses spécialisées.
On en compte actuellement
1100 infirmìeres praticiennes
900 de plus d'ici trois ans.
L'environnement, ici, est idéal.
Et les étudiants et étudiantes
vont contribuer aux services
offerts.
STÉPHANIE GUINDON, chef dévelop.
compétences, CISSS de Lavalirirr
les patients, ils vont évaluer
papapatients pour décider :
diagnostic, plan de traitement.
Ils vont retourner voir
ensuite et ensemble ils vont
décider siplplplan de traitement
qui avait été décidé était
acceptable.
un environnement dernier cri;
un élément de plououour séduire
d'éventuels candidats à
la profession d'infirmière.
dans notre campus. Ça nous
permet d'aller à nos c,,,
après, de venir en stage en
soirée.
- Ici Davide Genti